hey guys it's the Evan Kaitlyn podcast
the show recommended by three out of ten
cats and it's not that the other seven
didn't like it they just couldn't be
bothered to fill out the survey alright
guys so in today's podcast we are going
to be covering working together we get a
lot of questions about it it seems I try
to look for them but I couldn't find as
I thought but we're gonna kind of be
covering that then we're gonna play a
game called to defend yourself which is
kind of hilarious because our main topic
is working together and how we were
arguing and then we're gonna do things
of the week again you didn't do it so
this is our first Monday episode it is
it's not that big of a change to you
guys but it's exciting they work we're
figuring out the podcast it's becoming
more and more of a known quantity I
guess quantity yeah that's the thing
that people say like sound smart like
the podcast is becoming more of a known
quantity right listen am I using that
right I think of like the number of
orders we get each week is becoming more
of a known quantity like when the known
thing is a number can you use that her
honesty is a known quantity so it
doesn't just have to be like a I think
it's a real phrase person or known thing
whose nature or value is well known we
try to hire people who are a known
quantity in the field of blink
I feel lied to my entire life your whole
life is a lie
not known quality you're gonna have to
take that up with like the English rule
people because they are wacky they don't
answer my emails they are wacky they are
all over the place they're all making up
rules like just talk to the guy who
named like who figured out how to spell
Colonel in black no Jim Gaffigan
[Laughter]
recycled moving on this is also I think
the first week where we're gonna be
making three different pieces of content
we have the podcast coming out on Monday
we have our Tuesday be coming out on
Tuesday our Tuesday coming out onto our
G&K Tuesday ruk Tuesday coming on
Tuesday and then our main Friday video
that's that's that's pretty decent
content it's a lot of content I guess
it's a good week to talk about like how
we don't kill each other
III have to say I like that we are doing
three different pieces of content
instead of trying to do two main video
contents per week because I think that
would be more stressful than doing three
different things and doing twitch
sometimes but it feels like the variety
keeps things fresh and exciting yeah I
would agree with that
yeah all right so moving over to the
main content working together one one of
the some of the questions that we've
gotten like I pulled a few specifically
how do we pull it off what keeps you
going without driving each other nuts
and do we have fights yeah so I guess to
pull it off that's kind of a little bit
vague er like how do we pull off I guess
I guess all of these things kind of like
the same answers kind of answer all of
these questions yes I can talk about
like how we work together and that I'll
answer all of those yes and whether or
not we fight and how we tackle
disagreements so we actually started
talking about this while we were on one
of our walks which is one of our
strategies for keeping up good
communication whenever we are like
confused about something or stressed
about something we talk and since
Caitlyn cannot stand still while talking
we have to go in walks but we started
talking about this on the walk and
recognized save it for a podcast episode
because this is pretty interesting so we
haven't fully talked about it with each
other I totally forgot to but I have
some ideas in my head okay I think one
thing that really helps us stay
away from fighting or anything is we
have a shared vision for how to move
forward why we're doing this why is it
important to us and all of that and
since we have that shared vision we know
we're on the same team and anything that
I'm upset about or you're upset about is
the thing that we can work together
through as opposed to it being miiverse
you or vice versa
yeah because usually if one of us is
upset about something like it's it's
kind of like a side thing related to our
main quest and the main quest is the
same we're talking about video games
yeah it's like we have the main class
and the side objectives and side quests
yeah yeah but like figuring out that
challenge is like a side quest and the
main quest is still the main quest for
both of us it's so true going to do you
guys have five suite I'm kind of doing
things out of order but I have a reason
why I'm jumping ahead yeah we haven't
ever really had a fight we have been
upset the past and then we work together
to figure out why the other person's
upset and how to avoid getting upset in
the future but I think relating to
content creation I think one of the most
common moments when we get upset is at
the very beginning of a video that's
honestly the hardest part of making
YouTube videos yeah very beginning it's
a lot of stress that's when people
decide whether to stay or to leave and
that's how you set the tone that it's
the most important part of the entire
video creation process is the beginning
well I think one thing that used to get
us a little bit as we would be like we'd
put a lot of pressure on ourselves to
start filming we'd be like okay we're
gonna start this project today and then
we try to start it and then realize oh
we got it and then we try to start and
be like oh we forgot to do research on
that or oh we forgot to design that yeah
and then it would be you know 8:00 at
night before we even got started and
we'd be so frustrated because our goal
was to start the project
it's like expectation versus reality
hitting you in the face exactly and that
would be really frustrating to both of
us and you know that just makes it
easier to get frustrated at each other
when like you're frustrated at the
situation but one thing we did to
reframe that was like okay
yeah we want to get started on the
project today realizing that we need
materials that's getting started on the
project yeah starting the research or
start even starting we call like the
metadata like doing that like if there's
any outline if there's any talking
points we need to hit if there's like
you know all of the stuff that goes into
the behind-the-scenes that is starting
the project too because that's all time
there's going to go into the project so
I think reframing some things really
helped in that way yeah and I think also
kind of tied to that is sometimes you
know when we would start we would have
different ideas of like what the tone of
the video was gonna be or what the intro
style would be or whatever like even if
like the whole focus of the video if I
think it's about the build and Caitlin
thinks it about this about the story or
something like that that can be a
mismatch - yeah so like and we kind of
we divide and conquer a little bit when
it comes to videos like I'm usually
keeping track in my head of okay what
shots do we have what shots do we need
to get next is this gonna be montage is
this gonna be talking is this gonna be
time-lapse so I'm kind of keep like
editing the video in my head as we go
yeah because you do that editing work in
posts so one thing we found to really
speed up editing a post as if you edit
during the film you decide what it's
gonna be
and that's important but Caitlin's focus
on that and I'm thinking about okay so
what is the best order of operations for
cutting the wood to length and how to
assemble it and the mechanical aspects
and all of that and like the the project
actually working I feel that pressure
because that's kind of my responsibility
so I am focused on one side of things
and Caitlin's focus on the other side of
things and when we don't communicate
those needs and something gets thrown
off in some way that's when we can like
get upset and then we yeah just go for a
walk the solution isn't going on a walk
so it's just good communication just
talking about it and like acknowledging
that like okay I can recognize that
we're not on the same
h-here yeah fix that we need to get on
the same page and to get on the same
page we needed to talk yeah but I think
like you know a lot of people you know
not just people in relationships but if
you're working together in some capacity
usually there's some form of divide and
conquer hmm you know and like with us
you know you having the like thinking
about more the design and will it work
and me thinking about like can we turn
this into a video like a common example
of what would happen is you might start
making the thing and in your mind you
just need to get some preliminary things
done to figure out if it's even gonna
work and in my mind I'm thinking wait
why are you working on stuff I need to
film that what if it's a mess-up and
then that's funny and like it helps tell
the story of why we did it in a
different way you know you know we've
learned that like you communicate to me
if it's like okay I need to work on this
and it's not important for the story and
I'll communicate to you hey if you're
gonna do something important to the
story and I'm not ready you let me know
so I can film it things like that I
think that that is an interesting
example of a specific thing for us but I
think trying to broaden it out to a
bigger idea or concept what we have done
is as we've worked together and figured
out the process of creating videos we
have run into scenarios where we might
get upset and when that happens we try
to meet and figure out why we got upset
and then prevent that for the future and
then we've noticed patterns in the
moments when we get upset yeah so
oftentimes it's in the beginning of the
project so what we've started doing is
trying to meet before the project get on
the same page and all of that and then
the points like the the sticking points
that used to the sticking points that
used to get us or get us frustrated
aren't happening as much because we've
identified what those points are and we
try to prevent those from even happening
so instead of getting upset again and
again and again and again we and then
knowing that that's a point we get upset
at we kind of cut and I don't know what
I know the words I'm saying but we like
prevent it before it happens we prevent
it before it happens
you know in any type of relationship
like people can have fights and people
can be upset at each other I think like
because we have so many different levels
of relationship going on like we're
married
we're also like co-owners of a company
we work together literally all day every
day which is awesome by the way yeah
highly recommend but like there's no
room to stay upset at each other and
there's no room to not fix things and we
were like that even before we started
working together like if there was like
a hint of some of one of us being upset
about something like we would talk about
it before it became a big deal and
that's maybe not for everybody some
people might think like oh why do you
bring up every little thing but for us
it was just weird is over communicators
and that's how we both work but I think
especially like we're working together
we can't do what we do and like secretly
be fuming because we're so mad at the
other person you know well but also the
type of content we're trying to create
we're trying to inspire people to try
new things we're trying to show how
creating stuff can be fun and if we're
upset it's not gonna work it's not gonna
work one one thing I thought of that's
interesting that that might be a topic
we can kind of dive down into is how do
we decide the balance of our interests
because we have shared interests but we
also have divergent interests
I like CNC and 3d printing a little bit
more and you you aren't opposed to that
but I think that both of us have certain
interests and and how do you tend to
like the things work that are slightly
artsy or like the resin and and I like
those - yeah you like me - you like even
more I mean I like the cost but I like
everything I think I don't know but I
feel like there are some projects that
you lead the charge for or for in terms
of the beard okay the beard is like
almost all kids really wanted that beard
well I really wanted to decorate your
beard you giving me a beard was that
that was not your idea yeah yeah which
was brilliant
I think the things I want to do more I
think like don't really work on our
channel so it's less of a thing and we
are like you know we did do the silly
beard videos yeah
some of our like Ian K Tuesday videos
have been kind of silly and the one
that's coming out yeah that was
something I really wanted to do but I
think that's why we probably run in more
often to things where it's like you're
more excited about it than I am
rather than me being more excited about
it than you are because you're pretty
excited about like all of them make me
sad I'm going about everything but I
also love the videos that you want to
make to like like the tomorrow's videos
are mostly all about our cat and it's
awesome I had a lot of fun making it's
possum that pun only works if it's
written otherwise but I think that one
thing that helps with this is both of us
realizing that we're each a hundred
percent necessary for what we're doing
to work that's true and I think I used
to get a little bit more discouraged
about it going back to like CNC and 3d
printing that is not my strength all the
digital fabrication stuff like I know a
very small amount of what's crazy you
know more than probably 90% of the
population maybe but it doesn't feel
that way
like I don't do my own horn but I know a
lot like the maker community I feel like
there's a lot of people that know a lot
more than I do and so you know sometimes
with projects like that I feel like I
can contribute a lot less or at least
that's like how it would feel because I
don't know step 1 step 2 step 3 well if
we run into a problem I might get lucky
and guess how to fix up but I don't
really know how to fix it so I used to
feel like I wasn't adding anything by
being part of the project you know and
that was something I kind of struggled
with and I think I've gotten better at a
like
just being okay with the fact that like
not every single project has to be 50/50
involvement from us like even with the
shed that was you know I I helped with
it but I didn't mostly filming you know
or I was a helping hand and it's cuz you
know we're dealing with really big heavy
boards stuff that's high up that's hard
for me to hurricane-like logistics
there's a lot of things that just made
more sense if you did it yeah and like
I've gotten to a point now where it's
like it doesn't you know I used to just
feel like I had to we had to be 50/50
each of us on camera contributing to the
project and if I wasn't doing it I like
wasn't pulling my weight you know but
now I think I've gotten better at
accepting that like all of the
camerawork and film work and editing and
even though a lot of that's behind the
scenes and it's not what's seen by
people it is still obviously like a big
part that's the whole part but that's an
entire most important part the video
that comes out of what we do is the
product I think it is the product but
you know it's it wouldn't there would be
no video if there's no project yeah you
know but that I think that's that's like
a good point it's like without both of
us being fully part of this would have
nothing yeah no it's very true yeah
that's very true
I think there's like knowing that you
are both so important really helps you
know I think that we when we both have
equal buy into what we're doing you know
we're both fully on board with the same
vision and we're both excited about
where we're going yeah well I think
that's a big part of it too is there's
you know I mean if you look at YouTube
as a whole there's a lot of couples and
stuff like that to have channels but at
least in the maker community where like
you're coming together and you're doing
projects together which is kind of a
stereotypical point of contention
between couples is like like there's not
too much - too many couples doing this
but I think like or too many couples
that are like business owners together I
don't know I'm not sure how many there
are sometimes couples that are doing
stuff together but
often times it seems like there's like a
lead person sometimes yeah
but so like I guess I guess what I was
getting at and this is something you
touched on before is like we have equal
buying and everything really is Evan and
Caitlin there is no like yeah there's no
sidekick here it's the heroes I can
always defend myself because you chose
evidence but I guess like you know if if
one person was trying to run a maker
YouTube channel by themselves and they
were in the garage at all hours of the
night or like working all day you know
all these things that we we do so we
know it happens yeah and the other
person wasn't part of that then I think
it's a lot easier to have
misunderstandings and like hurt feelings
you know like because if one person is
spending all their time on work and the
other person doesn't get to see them
it's like man I want to see my
significant other yeah this sucks but
like if we're working all the time we're
working together and we know why we're
working all the time you know yeah so
I'm not sure how to turn that into
advice for other people I think they
were in a very unique situation we are
yeah we are I mean I guess it doesn't
necessarily have to every one specific
situation is different so it doesn't
have to be advice I think the biggest
advice is just communicating and like I
mean if you are in a situation where
you're not doing it together maybe try
bringing in that other person in some
way you know even if it's not even if
it's more of like behind the scenes way
yeah even if just talking and
brainstorming ideas and things like that
I think one thing that also helps is
since we're both fully bought into this
the winds are so much bigger sharing
those winds and hopefully there are some
a lot of winds but also even when there
is a failure sharing that failure and
understanding what went into it and
being able to like comfort each other
yeah through that you know it makes it
just makes everything
how's that everything is more better
aren't as low in the highs are higher
yeah yeah no it's super true cuz it's
like you have this other person that
understands everything like every aspect
of everything that you're going through
whether it's like all the work that went
into a win or why a lo suck so much
yeah I think it's a whole another topic
we might get into later about how doing
what we're doing is such a new and small
thing that people do not too many people
understand it yeah and having someone
who really understands that is really
valuable but I think the we could almost
a yeah it's good stuff but it's it's
yeah it's something we should talk about
in another podcast yeah I think so I
think one last aspect that I think might
be interesting to touch on is the
difference between real life and YouTube
that could kind of be another whole
topic yeah actually that could be a
whole nother podcast but I think that I
can touch on a few things that I think
are interesting about comparing real
life to YouTube life when we're making
videos we film a lot and we cut all the
highlights together just because a lot
of times we are just sitting together
companionably just work working on
things you know companionable scientist
Islands annual science and I think that
that's also a nice aspect of what we do
just being able to have children YouTube
content yeah I mean we've had some
really really nice tool time just like
hanging out together in the garage like
listen to podcast is painting and
standing and whatever we're doing yeah
doing stuff that like a lot of it
doesn't make it to the video
yeah and we do make each other laugh a
lot and we have a lot of fun and some of
it is just so I'm not no weirdo no I say
we're so weird
but you know there's a lot of stuff that
wouldn't be funny because there's a lot
of inside jokes and like a lot of stuff
that would take more time than would be
funny to explain it's cut on the funny
end so I still think it's a reflection
of who we are and our life in some ways
but it's also you know it's it's it's
like social media all over the place
it's the highlights yeah strung together
so I can see why like it people are
looking at that it it you know it of
course looks like we never have
disagreements or anything because
they're just seeing like the highlights
of what we're doing is that what you
were getting at like sending it back -
no I was actually kind of buying it -
one thing I saw a lot when when I was
looking through the comments is about
how we have we're always having so much
fun together and we generally are but I
don't want people to think that we are
just always laughing and always it's
like we do love what we're doing but
it's also a lot of work and that could
be a whole so much I think one last
thing when it comes to like getting
along doing projects together I do think
one thing to keep in mind is like we are
in a unique position not only because we
work together but because like I guess
it's because we work together like the
projects that we do in some ways there's
more pressure because it's our job now
you know so like things have to be on
time and things have to be good and and
all of that but on the other hand
because it's our job and because we can
do so many projects and we can do so
many videos if one doesn't turn out
perfect for some reason it's okay yeah
you know it's like oh we we tried making
you know concrete and resin gems from a
potato it was really fun it didn't like
it worked - okay but it wasn't like it
wasn't a resounding success yeah but
it's like you know and it just comes to
doing projects the video is our product
like you're saying earlier not the
project so if the project itself doesn't
turn out perfect it's okay you know and
I think sometimes especially because a
lot of people when they're working on
projects together it's like something
for their house there's a lot more
pressure for it to be perfect because
you're spending a lot of money you're
spending a lot of your extra time
outside of your normal job yeah to make
this thing happen and so I feel like
there is kind of more pressure on it in
some ways ya know I mean does that make
sense yeah so I think keys to happiness
expectation versus reality yes yes
that's it yeah
problem solved all right on to game time
we call it a segment defend yourself all
right so we have a hat here full of
things that we've written down these
things are random stances some that we
agree with some that we disagree with we
each put in equal amounts and I haven't
seen Evans and he hasn't seen mine and
when I opened this statement right here
I need to defend it vigorously
whether it's my statement or his
statement whether he believes it or not
and we're just gonna see how many of
these we get through all right let's
start with mechanical pencils are
superior to old-school pencils they are
so much better they have a consistent
width they are refillable infinitely
they last longer they're just better in
every single way you know but the thing
that you can't do with mechanical
pencils is with with a normal pencil you
can shape it to be what you want if
you're shading something you can
scribble on the side of the pencil and
then you have like a flat service that
you can shade with you can't do it with
a mechanical pencil yeah they have
really thick led mechanical pencils that
are like really huge like a quarter inch
thick yeah but you can't get it at the
correct angle a normal pencil if you go
with like the point of the pencil it's
flat and parallel with the paper with a
mechanical pencil it is a if you can
imagine my my hands doing this motion
right now it's like a mountain with a
straw straw
like coming out ahead you can't you
can't like put that against paper and
get it flat you'd have to stick the let
out so far yeah you can get like eighth
inch thick lead and you can do the exact
same thing your your point seven
millimeter lied your point five
millimeter level your point eight
millimeter LED and all the different
pencils and all the different LEDs but
so much to keep track of I know for a
fact that you would not keep track of
that that's a good counterpoint but this
the the the potential superiority of
mechanical pencils are much greater
and then there's real life support
superiority which is real pencils you
can you can you don't run out of lead
you know you run out of pencil you can
you can do that thing where you break it
you have two pencils on one pencil which
is really cool okay let's go ahead and
call it here the end of arguments who
won I won you won Iowa so that was one
that you had written I had written that
one tiny sheds are the best sheds big
sheds are the best sets you there
future-proof the last forever
big you got to get permits for that you
can't just do it on on your own you have
to put so much more work into making it
structurally sound yeah but in the
future if we had have gone with a big
shed we're gonna put AC into it we could
have used as a workshop we could have
done welding in there we could have
turned into a welding space but what
about this what about this what if in
the future we wanted a pool in our yard
and a big shed was taking up a bunch of
space that could have been a pool so
maybe a tiny shed is much we could have
done is we could have built a moat
around the shed and have an island said
however good out of it huh
so I think I can see in your eyes your
eyes this glow and you love that idea
to turn our shed into an island it's
tiny
it just means less digging for the boats
it's hard to defend the big ship we know
that C is on my side so I know that I
want re counting wins yes good like some
opinions there's just a right side to
things it's almost like luck of the draw
you could argue the other one so well so
passionately it's so well and some of
there's not a right answer okay gosh
come on okay tomatoes are the most
supreme fruit they are tasty they are
good on burgers ketchup salsa finger
load this salsa hey I know you're lying
because you don't like them on burgers
salsa though I mean like how could you
not have tomatoes and so those are that
food that you pick out of everything
because they're just watery and mush I'm
gonna try the soldiers do this because I
agree with you but tomatoes are the best
fruit I mean what other food can compare
what like like raspberries come on you'd
much rather you have no I'm cheese
tomato cheese and that forfeit by
forfeit that was a cheap shot
hey I actually believe that tomatoes are
the best fruit what how because they
make salsa any other fruit but that's
where I was going but that's the only
thing they got going for it
salsa and that's the drawing I did on it
socks with sandals are the best form of
footwear no there are plenty of much
better for fun just flip-flops you don't
need those sandals and also when I'm for
those socks when you put socks and
sandals together it creates that wedgie
that's way too big and then just like
it's really uncomfortable you get sweaty
like wedgie just right it's like really
nice
just sandals or like better like like so
what's the ideal use case for like socks
and sandals it's because my feet are
cold but I don't want to put on shoes
that I can't just slip on and off easily
so okay so in cold weather is when you
are saying that it's the best we're in
hot weather because sometimes my feet
are also cold and hot weather okay okay
so when your feet are cold
that's basically it yeah why not just
wear boots boots aren't as freeing fuzzy
boots
I gotcha all right my turn but I know
you love sandals no I do too Star Wars
is better than Star Trek that is far
superior everyone knows more Star Wars
references everyone knows what Star Wars
is some people don't even know what Star
Trek is when people think they know Star
Trek is there really this thing about
Star Wars you know I know what Star Trek
is and it's the one with beam me up
Scotty and so which version of Star Trek
is your favorite which captain is your
favorite it's so memorable right William
Shatner okay well other captains were
there what's the Star Trek captain's
name okay now what's the bad guy in Star
Wars only give receipts if it is
requested it is a waste of paper to give
me a receipt when I don't ask for a
receipt but what if what if you need to
receive but you're too shy and then you
just don't get a receipt what if you
needed for business purposes and you can
expense it well then you need to ask
that's not that's on
you that's not on the person giving like
making the decision to give you the
receipt yeah but you know if they stop
making receipts
how are the paper companies gonna make
money anymore you're ruining the economy
you know there's better things that
paper can be used for than receipts it
can be used on sticky notes that are
used or defend yourself cake and we can
place so much more of this think of how
new Krista you know it's weird ass if
nobody had to make receipts what what if
like when you take into order and you
get the order number what if like they
say your number and you're supposed to
remember it and you forget and you never
get your food ever this it's okay sadly
when you go they don't even check your
receipt number here you actually are
like kind of having better arguments
than me and you wrote you wrote this is
not defending it that well there's
there's one really big no there's two
big defenses okay one trees trees trees
you gotta save the trees to landfill
most people when they get a receipt they
they're not at a location where there's
recycle okay let me just join them
because I hate receipts I just don't
want to deal with him I did it end up
littering my pockets my car they walled
up things in the washer but there's such
a waste I get rid of mine immediately
because I don't want that but then I
feel super guilty because you know if
you just like at a fast food or CVS or
whatever you're just gonna throw it in
the trash and then it's like there's no
recycling option it's so much easier to
default op out as opposed to like as
opposed to like are printing it you're
already printing it yeah all right you
win that just forget I agree you argue
really well thank you thank you
let's see what this one is
Philips head is the worst and it should
never exist all Phillips heads should be
replaced with star drive with square
drive with anything like driver
technology has advanced so far now mr.
Phillips when you first invented the
Philips head screwdriver
okay that's great it's self centers
that's great you push it in and it's
holding it centered but you know what
mr. Philips your invention has been
obsoleted it's no longer needed and you
should you should this concede defeat
even though you're already probably dead
then you should move on and make room
for the better drive technologies I rest
my case
you know but there's so many Phillips
head out there what's what's the most
common we'll see iconic screw head start
drive no it's a Philips if you look up
screwed screwdriver icons or screw icon
Oh that'd be like saying you know we
should always a stick with VHS tapes
because they're the most iconic way of
recording video and you know let's just
stick with vinyl forever let's not go to
this mp3 thing change that would have to
happen in order to chain it be like
going to metric for the US yeah maybe it
makes more sense but think of everything
that all the IKEA furniture I know that
y'all uses like Allen dress Allen's
better I'll be fine with Allen taking
Philips place just like they pop out
basically strip their this is the worst
they're the worst
it wouldn't cost anything more like to
to make other types of screw head screw
designs like it's all gonna cost the
same yeah yeah it's so much better that
that that bad topic right there is that
the the single event that inspired this
whole game to mr. Phillips come on
I think the mender was actually named
mr. Phillips okay the gaps in bathroom
stalls is two large gaps and bathroom
stars stalls are way too large it's not
there's no privacy there's no reason
that they need to be that big over the
UK they're not that big there yeah but
like so so what if like you go to a
stall and you wonder if someone's in
there
you don't like peek underneath that
happens ok but like what if what if a
really hard one to defend no no there's
no way that they should be that big like
what like what you're doing in there is
private you know what when it comes to
like the design of the doors it's a lot
cheaper to manufacture this style of
door with door piece itself is separate
there's more wiggle room easily designed
so there's a tiny gap there's less metal
used and so it's more cost-efficient
that gap if you think of all the gaps in
the world Beauty millions of dollars
millions of dollars worth of steel doors
you know what
that all of the costs in the labor the
assembling and all of that like the the
small increase in material is negligent
when you think about all the bathroom
doors in all of the land it's all thin
sheet metal or like was BV no no it's
all air in there super thing that's
another thing airflow it helps with the
air you know I bet air foil and that
will make everybody else leaves do you
have your privacy okay for defending
myself champion alright let's move on to
things of the week my thickness of the
week are something that we found when we
were working with Alex teal this is
something that uses all of the time it's
the Manfrotto
two four four variable friction that
magic arm with camera bracket and the
Manfrotto super clamp with standard stud
those combine during like how does he
remember the numbers that it's a man
throat Oh - I was trying to be super
smart here super not what are you trying
to say I can defend myself myself
champion they're so versatile they clamp
to anything and sometimes tripods just
can't get to the places these can get
and they're so easily repositionable you
know and you can't fit a tripod and walk
around and ruin your project seeing Alex
he'll use his was incredibly inspiring
how he repositioned to get all these
very interesting camera angles that's
how he gets a lot of his shots with this
magic arm and we have ours now and we
were just using at other day they
capture a shot that would just would
have been a painting otherwise and it's
it's great yeah we can put a link to it
it's a really cool thing yeah there'll
be a link in the description on our
YouTube channel it'll be clickable
depending on your podcast app it may or
may not be clickable but it'll be there
yeah okay so my pick of the week is
Mythbusters junior has the same feel it
has the same like pace and there's
nothing really lost from Mythbusters
that still feels Mythbusters and yet
they're incorporating like new new humor
I love that they let everyone have their
own sense of humor and personality and
it felt very natural yeah yeah like even
though even from like Episode one where
you think they go everyone's just kind
of getting used to being on camera
introduced like being introduced as the
hardest part the hardest part like you
would think like oh man it's you know a
lot of kids who've never been on TV
before like you know but they everyone
was like such a natural and more natural
than we were in our first youtube video
yeah it was really funny like we were
only on the second episode but the
projects are awesome so far so if you
are a fan of
the original Mythbusters you will love
it I would highly recommend have you
recommend yeah plus my friend Ally isn't
it alright well hey I think that marks
the end of the episode thank you so much
for joining us again on this podcast
we'd really appreciate it we've gotten
our first reviews on iTunes I don't know
if I can respond to them but it's really
exciting number 71 podcast number 71 and
the hobby in games category I'm sure if
that's the best category to be I don't
know it's like categorize yourself we
like making stuff is kind of like I
don't know let me play games hobbies a
game it's perfect
wonder how high we can get in the
rankings we just pick like the easiest
category to rank and guys remember one
3m fishing but seriously it doesn't mean
a lot that you guys have left us reviews
and that you've subscribed to the
YouTube channel which is youtube.com
slash Evan Kalin podcast um yeah it's a
really great hearing everyone's feedback
so far and we'll look forward to talking
to you next time all right we are live
we're not live we're not streaming this
is what we're recording whoopsy Evan and
Caitlin didn't move see what we did an
oopsie
while we are live-streaming we thought
that we turned off the camera and we
farted I was thinking farting at first
but that wouldn't be really an oopsie
oopsie the fart oopsie oopsie